here's the reality of it with Tate the
biggest challenge he's going to have is
what how much can the world consume that
content before they get over it is it a
one-year thing is it a three-year thing
is it a five or tenure I think he's not
going away for a while
I think he is very attractive I think
he's very entertaining I think he's also
a great Storyteller I think he makes
very good points I think he is
multi-dimensional he doesn't just talk
about dating he talks about politics he
talks about religion he talks about
Finance he'll talk about sports he'll
talk about fighting when you're that
multi-dimensional you can be in any room
and you can be interesting most people
are not very multi-dimensional if you
were actually to sit there and take the
top 20 content creators who are out
there going viral and you were to say
who are multi-dimensional Tate's on that
list Logan Paul is multi-dimensional you
know you got you don't have that many
people that are that multi-dimensional